the bad news the next-gen version of The
Witcher 3 The One released on
PlayStation 5 and series X and S still
has some problems the good news you're
going to be able to play Dead Island 2
sooner than you expected let's start
with Witcher because CD projekt Red has
confirmed that it is now working on
multiple patches following the release
of patch 4.01 one of the glaring issues
plaguing the game is bad performance on
next-gen consoles the players reporting
a noticeable decrease in frame rate
while in performance mode a decrease
that's especially noticeable in areas
like novograd patch 4.01 was released
earlier this month for next-gen consoles
and PC and introduced a variety of
improvements mainly focusing on overall
stability and performance while also
adding a new performance mode for Ray
Trace Global illumination and more
alongside some general system issues the
developer is looking into it also
explained that the battle preparations
Quest that was meant to be fixed with
the last patch still isn't resolved cdpr
said quote we are aware that some
players who experienced an issue where
it could be impossible to interact with
avalock before patch 4.01 may now
experience an issue where there are no
dialogue options that can progress the
quest after the fix we're working on the
underlying cause and steps to reproduce
it and it turns out Witcher isn't the
only game with update issues earlier
this month Ubisoft announced it was
still laying the 11th season of the
division 2 because of a localization
problem last week the developer provided
another statement that confirmed a
system error affected its ability to
update the game the dev explained that
it would extend the previous season's
activities due to the delay but can't
because of the current situation as it's
quote unable to make server or
client-side updates until the build
generation system is restored and
speaking of being restored my faith in
Dead Island 2 is stronger than ever the
release date for the game is changing
once again but for the first time it's
not a delay instead publisher Deep
Silver has announced that the action RPG
will launch one week earlier on April
21st 2023 to reinforce this day Deep
Silver tweeted that Dead Island 2 has
gone gold as well back in November the
zombie game set in Los Angeles was
pushed back 12 weeks from February to
April 28th so this rearrangement helps
shorten that delay that said it's been a
rocky development cycle for the game
Dead Island 2 was originally unveiled at
E3 2014 as part of the Sony press
conference since then the game has seen
multiple delays and even switched Studio
hands a couple times on a scale of 1 to
10 let me know in the comments where
your hype levels are at for Dead Island
2. we'll see you tomorrow
foreign